ivermectin is a very good drug its  safetiness has been proven for decades  it even won a nobel peace prize  and it is absolutely irresponsible for  the biden administration uh the cdc  dr fauci and any of these doctors to be  advising people to to not prescribe it  isn't that just the best so two layers  of confusion here first of all  ivermectin didn't win any nobel prize  and it definitely didn't win a nobel  peace prize there are two scientists  william campbell and satoshi amura  won a nobel prize in 2015  for discovering that a modified version  of ivermectin called avermectin could be  used  to treat infections  caused  by roundworm parasites  nothing about a nobel peace prize  nor anything about ivermectin to treat  covet so consider the fallacious  reasoning here but this is the type of  stuff these right-wingers love they  latch onto it